empecemos por hablar Qué significa este
mundial para Argentina especialmente
teniendo en cuenta que hace dos años
murió Maradona la gran figura del fútbol
Argentino
bueno Qué tal Buenos días para todos por
la invitación y realmente hace un
triunfo inolvidable va a ser inolvidable
para todos aquellos que pintan hasta 40
años no que que nunca vieron a la
Argentina o más de años Porque eran muy
chicos cuando Argentina pudo lograr el
título allá por 1986 de esta manera es
como una reivindicación futbolística y
deportiva Y por qué no cultural de de
todo un pueblo que volcó a la calle
masivamente para para festejar Este
triunfo
ahora Señor Guillermo Les saluda Luis
Méndez desde acá desde Bogotá quisiera
hablar un poco en medio de este contexto
económico con una inflación de El 80%
anual también en problemas severos a
nivel económico Cómo se siente Este
triunfo a nivel social dentro de la
población
Y qué tal Buenos días para ti
es una reivindicación a nivel digamos
amorosa con el fútbol y con el deporte
si se puede decir de alguna manera es
una una reivindicación de un pueblo que
sufre que que tiene limitaciones en una
gran parte de su población pero que
nunca deja de lado lo deportivo porque
nos lleva como una bandera lo llevó
durante años al lado Diego Armando
Maradona y parecería
a mí me al menos me da la sensación que
Lionel Messi la pudo levantar recién
Cuando digo falleció no pudo realmente
sentir la camiseta número diez en su
espalda no quita Es el medio
jugar por la Argentina hace muchos años
muchos años
Que él debutó con la camiseta Argentina
siendo un chico en un amistoso frente a
Paraguay en la cancha de argentino
Juniors donde el máximo ídolo
o uno de los más conocidos del fútbol
mundial debutó allá por 1976 así que
creo que Messi entendió que él era el
protagonista de esta historia y los fue
de hecho lo fue y no es casualidad que
haya sido declarado como el mejor
jugador del mundial bueno Y usted nos
hablaba de esa combinación de las
pasiones del fútbol con las situaciones
políticas y económicas del país y en las
dos ocasiones anteriores en las que
argentina se coronó como el campeón del
mundial ya pasó que los gobiernos del
momento hicieron alardes y se hicieron y
ganaron réditos con el éxito de la
albiceleste cuéntanos un poco Cómo
fueron esas victorias anteriores Y cómo
se las tomaron los gobiernos
una sin lugar a dudas
sobre el campeonato de 1978 Por lo cual
y trataron de hacerla a toda Costa
sacaron político de alguna manera
mientras muchos ciudadanos argentinos
desaparecen de sus casas de sus hogares
Y nadie sabía muy bien de qué se trataba
es un momento muy muy de la Argentina y
el festejo posterior yo recuerdo
Caminando por la cerca del obelisco
cuando el día lunes siguiente la gente
rondas en la calle sin saber muy bien de
qué se trataba si Argentina ganó un
campeón mundial o eh realmente lo que
sucedía en el ámbito político y social
en ese momento y refiriéndome a a 1986
recuerdo el festejo en la casa rosada de
los jugadores solamente en el balcón
ante una colmada de mayo En aquel
momento pero bueno Fueron momentos
distintos
único porque se han sumado personas en
cantidades cantidades incalculables a lo
largo de lo ancho del país a festejar
Este triunfo que muchos no vieron no
vieron ninguna vez a la Argentina
campeón solamente el año pasado campeón
de la Copa América en un momento de
pandemia en un momento donde todavía la
gente no se podía apuntar cómo lo está
haciendo ahora